we have some very interesting political
election
news in the texas sixth congressional
district republican primary this is two
republicans running against each other
uh the trump endorsed candidate lost and
it wasn't
a huge blowout but it was a loss and
this is our first
signal about 2022 which is going to
serve
to inform what happens in 2024 from the
standpoint of the republican
presidential candidate and whether that
will be
donald trump remember that we are
working backwards now
in 2024 republicans will need some uh
candidate to uh run for president the
question is is that going to be donald
trump well
trump running in 24 will be informed by
how do the trump-backed candidates do
in november of 2022 how do republicans
do in november of 2022
in the house and the senate well to get
to that
you have to start looking at some of the
primaries that are taking place
right now and in the uh texas sixth
congressional district
so far donald trump has one loss
in that texas uh congressional district
jake elsie the non-trump republican
has defeated the trump-backed rival
susan wright so chalk this up as a loss
for donald trump let's take a look
republican jake elsie of texas
won a house seat on tuesday night over a
rival backed by donald trump
dealing the former president a defeat in
a test of his endorsement power since
leaving office
elsie's come from behind victory over
republican susan wright the widow of the
late rep
ron wright is a special congressional
election runoff near dallas
is likely to be celebrated by trump
antagonists
who have warned against his continued
hold on the republican party
elsie was carrying more than 53 percent
of the vote in texas's sixth
congressional district with results
from almost all precincts reported one
of the things we've seen from this
campaign is a positive
outlook a reagan republican outlook for
the future of our country
is what the people of the sixth district
really really want elsie said to
supporters
the runoff election came down to the two
republicans in a race to succeed
congressman ron wright
who in february became the first member
of congress to die
after being diagnosed with covet 19.
susan wright a republican party activist
and widow of the late congressman
carried the endorsement of trump
into the special election runoff a few
differences in policy separated the
candidates
giving the race in north texas the feel
of a republican
primary far from running on an
anti-trump platform
elsie did not try distancing himself
from the twice impeached former
president
he instead sought to overcome the lack
of trump's backing by raising more money
and showing off endorsements including
that of rick perry so this is actually a
really big deal
in a sense 2024 is now and what i mean
by that is
we are getting into although we still
have a little while this was a special
runoff
we still have some months until they
really get going but we're starting to
get into primaries for 2022
which are going to determine what
happens in november of 2022
which will determine what happens in
2024 and
donald trump already backing some
primary candidates
and the first one here has lost this was
the trump candidate and they did not win
so this is you know it's a sample size
of one
we still don't know what it portends for
the bigger
idea of donald trump being a kin king
maker in 2022
uh but this is already an interesting
sign and when i was interviewed by
trump's former lawyer michael cohen a
couple of weeks ago
cohen said he doesn't think trump is
ultimately going to run
and the reason trump won't run is it's
going to be clear to trump that he's not
going to win
if he runs in 2024 that's michael
cohen's perspective
he may well be right he's been right
about many things and he's been you know
not right about some things if indeed
trump is going to be convinced that he's
not going to win
part of it will be that the people he
chooses the people he backs
for 2022 uh lose and that is at least
what we saw in the texas sixth
congressional district we'll have more
coverage of that race and others that
are upcoming
on the david pakman show instagram which
you can find at david pakman show
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company
best known for their delicious mushroom
coffee
four sigmatics mushroom coffee is
organic
fair trade single origin arabica coffee
with both lion's mane and chaga
mushrooms chaga mushrooms have actually
been shown to have potential in
supporting the immune system
in peer-reviewed studies i've been
drinking four
sigmatic coffee a lot lately it actually
doesn't taste anything like mushrooms it
just tastes like
any delicious coffee but it's really
easy on my stomach doesn't give me any
jittery feeling or a midday crash and
they have over
20 000 five-star reviews
and best of all if you don't love it
you'll get 100 percent
of your money back because they stand
behind their product
you've got nothing to lose by giving it
a try four sigmatic is giving my
audience up to forty percent
off and free shipping when you go to
four sigmatic dot com slash pacman
the link is right underneath this video